eric eric one other quick thing today is
the 25 year anniversary of uh
of the knicks trading pat riley to the
miami heat for a first round pick that
became walter mccarty
obviously that turned out to be a pretty
good trade
can you can you anniversary today 25
years today september 1st
1995. um
i'm just curious uh how did you receive
that news
at the time super nervous
uh i thought i would probably be out and
i would have been out uh
if it didn't end the way it did he
couldn't bring anybody from new york but
if he could have he was going to bring
jeff
i had heard and probably his whole staff
he was definitely going to bring
this video guy um so i thought i was the
very strong potential that i was going
to be out um
you know without it without a job going
into coaching in september that's that's
a tough
tough timing but i had already had some
good experience working
you know for the draft so i was i was
cool with that but i was definitely
definitely nervous obviously you fast
forward now and
i'm just extremely grateful for for all
these years
you know working for the godfather
he's been he really has been
an incredible blessing in my life
um you know it's uh
yeah you know you don't get me emotional
now that just takes me down
memory lane everybody knows how i feel
about pat
and how oh good uh it kind of surprised
me right now
a little emotional but um he's been
great for the
for the franchise that that partnership
of the riley's and the erisons
that'll go down all time in sports
um and how they've transformed this
franchise but also the city
city of miami been a great boost